hello my name is Raquel Rosa I came from  Brazil and I'm working for the German  national team I like to work with people  here with people from the dfb I like to  work with the French people to meet new  people I have to concentrate and see you  which journalists are here where they  come from which language could be it is  German or Spanish or Portuguese I never  know before I never know what they will  ask so i have to be there I have to be  ready that somebody will will make a  question so I have to switch as fast as  possible to this language and explain  and translate the question in German as  fast as possible I believe that we can  do to the final and win also we have a  great team we have great players a very  good coach and everything around is  working very very good